salut à tous aujourd'hui vidéo un petit
peu différente de ce que je fais
d'habitude car j'aimerais raisonner un
petit peu théoriquement par rapport à
une révélation de samuel jackson à
propos de captain marvel pour une fois
nous sommes proches d'une information
qui peut être quasiment considéré comme
un spoil de l'histoire de ventures 4
donc vous êtes prévenus vous êtes
toujours présent bien
résumons le crime samuel jackson plus
connus pour certains d'entre vous comme
le personnage de nick fiori a attribué
une interview à entertainment weekly
à propos de son prochain grand rôle dans
le film glace la suite de split qui sort
le 18 janvier au cinéma évidemment
samuel jackson joe nick fury dans la
saga de films marvel qui est totalement
sous les projecteurs en ce moment ils en
ont profité pour lui glisser quelques
questions à propos de captain marvel et
notamment avengers 4 nous en arrivons à
l'objet du débat
samuel a fait une gourde pas possible il
aurait apparemment et je précise sur le
apparemment ce pôle l intrigue du
personnage de captain marvel dans
l'univers d'avengers je vais vous lire
ce qu'il a déclaré elle est certainement
le personnage le plus fort en ce qui
concerne les pouvoirs de l'univers
marvel
donc pour carole denver ce d'être cette
personne et pour bris de devenir cette
personne sera de la dynamite les
avengers sont face à une menace très
difficile on l'a vu tout le long d'une
finity war maintenant on sait que l'on a
besoin de quelque chose d'aussi puissant
que thanos éventuellement on découvrira
à quel point elle est puissante et tout
ce dont elle est capable
c'est l'une des rares dans l'univers
marvel à être capable de voyager dans le
temps
alors avant d'entamer le sujet ce qu'il
dit nous l'avons théorisé déjà depuis un
moment et comme je voulais dit le voyage
dans le temps est une certitude pour moi
je ne souhaite pas seulement analyser ce
qu'il vient de dire mais remettre en
cause cette idée dans le mc eu il est
vrai que captain marvel et on sait
depuis une fi nit ivoire l héroïne qui
va vaincre thanos et ramener une
certaine paix elle est déclarée depuis
un très bon moment comme la plus
puissante des avengers et son teasing à
la fin définitive war est également une
réponse à tous ceux ci
captain marvel
l'héroïne qui va lancer la carrière de
nick fiori en quelque sorte c'est grâce
à elle que ce dernier va découvrir que
des super-héros existe et qu'elle est
loin d'être la seule
elle amène le monde des extraterrestres
et les super pouvoirs sur terre pour
simplifier tout ce qu'il dit n'est donc
pas étonnant le personnage le plus fort
ça va être le feu bref il est un petit
peu dans son personnage de nick fury
découvrant les super héros et confirme
tout ce qui avait été déclaré déjà
ensuite samuel à résume très clairement
infinity ward et nous adresse bien que
la menace d'abord george iv et bien
thanos rien de surprenant mais nous
décernons très facilement que captain
marvel est donc le seul personnage à
être aussi puissant que lui la seule qui
puisse lui tenir tête et donc pour
justifier son propos il amène alors la
fameuse phrase qui à réfléchir un bon
nom on découvrira à quel point elle est
puissante et tout ce dont elle est
capable
c'est l'une des rares dans l'univers
marvel à être capable de voyager dans le
temps
captain marvel pourrez voyager dans le
temps et d'après ce qu'il raconte
on comprend facilement que c'est ce
pouvoir qui permettrait de tenir tête à
la noce et de le défaire le pouvoir
qu'il a tiendrait au même rang qu lui
alors très bien
carole denver ce serait capable de
voyager dans le temps mais ne serait-ce
pas ultra tchité et surtout par quels
moyens pourrait-elle faire ceci il faut
être factuel dans cette situation et
bien réfléchir à ce qui nous est montré
malgré sa grande puissance
carole ne peut pas voyager dans le temps
d'un simple claquement de doigts je ne
vois donc que la dimension quantique
pour répondre à ce problème
la dimension quantique est un élément
tout aussi important que le personnage
de captain marvel a mené par le biais de
ventes man je vous invite à revoir mes
précédentes vidéos et notamment celle
sur le plan de doctor strange antoine de
et captain marvel sont deux films
sortant entre infinity ward et avengers
4 il amène donc des réponses pour
l'intriguent d'avengers 4 et nous les
avons la dimension quantique et captain
marvel effectivement captain marvel
tirent apparemment ses pouvoirs de la
dimension
comment on le remarque assez facilement
de parcé trailer néanmoins cette
déclaration remet en cause certaines
choses déjà comment ce pouvoir propre à
captain marvel va t'il être amenées je
vous rappelle déjà que la pierre du
temps et l'une des 6 singularité de
l'univers à un pouvoir divin par logic
captain marvel devrait avoir un pouvoir
tout de même assez amoindrie par rapport
à la pierre ou alors autant la
considérer comme une déesse
elle ne peut être plus puissante que la
pierre du temps à part si la dimension
quantique et sous côtés alors ça veut
dire de plus samuel affirme qu'elle est
l'une des rares à pouvoir voyager dans
le temps
qu'est ce que cela sous-entend l'une des
rares elle n'est donc pas seul à pouvoir
le faire on se tombe facilement vers
docteur strange par le biais de la
pierre mais je pense et surtout à
huntsman par le biais de la dimension
quantique
après antoine 2 le trailer d'avengers 4
nous le prouvent est justement
mais ce qui est sous-entendu également
dans les propos de samuel l unicité de
captain marvel
quelle est la plus puissante la seule à
tenir tête à thanos est ce que cela
voudrait potentiellement dire quelle
serait la seule à voyager dans le temps
dans avengers 4 pour réunir les pierres
avant la noce ou le tuer avant les
événements d infinity ward je ne peux
malheureusement rien de vous affirmer et
au contraire j'aimerais vous mettre en
garde
nous ne pouvons nous fier à 100% des
déclarations des acteurs que ce soit la
fin de contrat ou les faux spoiler comme
avengers annulation il reste tout à fait
plausible que ce qu'a dit samuel jackson
était prévu d' avance ses limites
obvious qu'il devait savoir qu'on me
poserais des questions sera avengers
néanmoins on se rappelle également que
mark ruffalo l'acteur de banner avait
avoué qu'à la fin d'une infiniti war
tout le monde allait mourir ou encore
tom holland interdit d'interviews
tellement il a la langue bien pendue je
vous laisse donc seuls juges de cette
déclaration mais ça mérite et je pense
une petite vidéo je vous invite à me
dire vos avis dans les commentaires et
ce que vous en pensez
je fais une dédicace à star rogers pour
m'avoir mis au courant de cette
déclaration
n'oubliez pas le petit pouce bleus et à
vous abonner c'est très important que le
liner soit avec vous cet argot rock
[Musique]